[Music]
hello everyone welcome to intro to
machine learning on Google cloud
platform my name is Sarah Robinson I'm a
developing developer advocate on the
Google cloud platform team and I focus
on machine learning you can find me on
twitter at s robb tweets so let's dive
right in by talking about what is
machine learning
so at a high level machine learning
involves teaching computers to recognize
patterns in the same way that our brains
do so as humans it's really easy for us
to distinguish between a cat and a dog
but it's much more difficult to teach a
machine to be able to do the same thing
in this talk I'm going to focus on
what's called supervised learning this
is when during training you give your
model labeled input and we can think of
almost any supervised learning problem
in this way so we provide labeled inputs
to our model and then our model outputs
a prediction now the amount that we know
about how our model works is going to
depend on the tool we choose to use for
the job and the type of machine learning
problem we're trying to solve so that
was a high-level overview but how do we
actually get from input to description
again this is going to depend on the
type of machine learning problem we're
trying to solve so on the left hand side
let's say you're solving a generic task
but someone has already solved before in
that case you don't need to start from
scratch but on the other side of the
spectrum let's say you're solving a
custom task that's very specific to your
data set then you're going to need to
build and train your own model from
scratch so more specifically let's think
of this in terms of image classification
so let's say we want to label this image
as a picture of a cat this is a really
common machine learning task there's
tons of models out there that exist to
help us label images so we can use one
of these pre trained models we don't
need to start from scratch
but let's say on the other hand that
this cat's name is Chloe this is our cat
and we want to identify her apart from
other cats across our entire image
library so we're gonna need to train a
model using our own data from scratch so
that it
differentiate Chloe from other cats more
specifically let's say that we want our
model to return a bounding box showing
where she is in that picture we're also
gonna need to train a model on our own
data let's also think about this in
terms of a natural language processing
problem so let's say we have this text
from one of my tweets and I want to
extract the parts of speech from that
text this is a really common natural
language processing task so I don't need
to start from scratch I can utilize an
existing NLP model to help me do this
but let's say on the other hand that I
want to take the same tweet and I want
my model to output these tags I want my
model to know that this is a tweet about
programming and more specifically it's a
tweet about Google Cloud I'm gonna need
to train my model on thousands of tweets
about each of these things so that it
can generate these predictions so many
people see the term machine learning and
they're a little bit scared off they
think it's something that's only for
experts now if we look back about 60
years ago this was definitely the case
this is a picture of the first neural
network invented in 1957 called the
perceptron and this was a device that
demonstrated an ability to identify
different shapes so back then if you
wanted to work on machine learning you
needed access to extensive academic and
computing resources but if we fast
forward to today we can see that just in
the last five or ten years the number of
products at Google that are using
machine learning has grown dramatically
and at Google we want to put machine
learning into the hands of any developer
and data scientists with a computer and
a machine learning problem that they
want to solve that's all of you we don't
think machine learning should be
something only for experts so if you
think about how you're doing machine
learning today maybe you're using a
framework like scikit-learn XG booze
chaos or tensor flow maybe you're
writing your code in Jupiter notebooks
maybe you're just experimenting with
different types of models building
proofs of concept or maybe you've
already built a model and you're working
on scaling it for production so what I
want you to take away from this talk
is that no matter what your existing
machine learning toolkit is we've got
something to help you on Google cloud
platform and that's what I'm going to
talk to you about today so we have a
whole spectrum of machine learning
products on GCP on the left hand side we
have products targeted towards
application developers to use these you
need little to no machine learning
experience on the right hand side of the
spectrum we have products that are
targeted more towards data scientists
and machine learning practitioners so
the first set of products I'll talk
about is our machine learning api's
these are api's that give you access to
pre trained models with a single REST
API request as we move toward the middle
we have a new product which I'm super
excited about that we announced earlier
this year in January called Auto ml it's
currently in alpha and the first Auto ml
products we've announced is Auto ml
vision so this lets you build a custom
image classification model train on your
own data without requiring you to write
any of the model code as we move further
to the right towards more custom models
if you want to build your modern model
and tensorflow we have a service called
cloud machine learning engine to let you
train and serve your model at scale then
a couple of months ago we announced an
open-source project called Kubb flow
this lets you run your machine learning
workloads on kubernetes
and then finally our most do-it-yourself
solution is let's say you have a machine
learning framework other than tensorflow
and you want to run it on GCP you can do
this using google compute engine or
google kubernetes engine but we don't
have tons of time today so we're gonna
focus just on three of these and let's
dive right in
starting with machine learning as an API
on Google cloud platform we have five
api's that give you access to pre
trained models to accomplish common
machine learning tasks so they let you
do things like analyzing images
analyzing videos converting audio to
text analyzing that text further and
then translating that text I'm going to
show you just two of them today so let's
start with cloud vision this is
everything the vision API lets you do so
at its core the vision aid
gie provides label detection this will
tell you what is this a picture of so
for this image of my return elephant
animal etc web detection goes one step
further and it'll search the web for
similar images and it'll give you labels
based on what it finds OCR stands for
optical character recognition this will
let you find text in your images tells
you where that text is and what language
it's in logo detection will identify
common logos in an image landmark
detection will find common landmarks
crop hints will suggest crop dimensions
for your photos and then explicit
content detection will tell you is this
image appropriate or not this is what a
request to the vision API looks like so
again you don't need to know anything
about how that pre-trained model works
under the hood you pass it either a URL
to your image in Google Cloud storage or
just the base64 encoded image and then
you tell it what types of feature
detection you want to run now it's just
a REST API so you can call it in any
language you'd like I have an example in
Python here using our Google Cloud
client library for Python I create an
image annotate our client and then I run
label detection and analyze the response
I'm guessing many of you heard about ml
kit announced a couple days ago so if
you want to use ml kit for firebase you
can easily call the vision API from your
Android or iOS app and this is an
example of calling it in Swift so I
don't like to get too far into a talk
without showing a live demo so if we
could switch to the demo and what we
have here is the product page for the
vision API here we can upload images and
see what the vision API response so I'm
gonna upload an image here this is a
selfie that I took seeing Hamilton I
live in New York I was super excited to
have scored tickets to Hamilton and I
wanted to see what the vision API said
about my selfie so let's see what we get
back here
it's cranking live demos you never know
how they'll go there we go ok so we can
see that it found my face in the image
so it's able to identify where my faces
different features in my face and it's
also able to detect emotion so we can
see that joy is very lie
here I was super excited to be seeing
Hamilton what I didn't notice at first
about this image is that it has some
text in it when I send it to the vision
API I didn't even notice that there is
text here but we can see that the API
using OCR is able to extract that
playbill text from my image and then
finally in the browser we can see the
entire JSON response we get back from
the vision API so this is a great way to
try out the API if before you start
writing any code upload your images in
the browser see the type of response you
get back and if it's right for your app
and I'll provide a link to this at the
end so that is the vision API if we
could go back to the slides next I'm
going to talk about the natural language
API which lets you analyze text with a
single REST API requests so the first
thing it lets you do is extract key
entities from text it also lets you
tells you whether your text is positive
or negative and then if you want to get
more into the linguistic details of your
text you can use the syntax analysis
method and finally the newest feature of
this API is content classification it'll
classify your texts into many of over
700 different categories that we have
available here's some Python code to
call the natural language API it's gonna
look pretty similar to the vision API
code we saw on the previous page and
again we don't need to know anything
about how this model works we just send
it our text and get back the result from
the model now let's jump to a demo of
the natural language API so again this
is our product page for the natural
language API and here we can enter text
directly in this text box and see what
the natural language API response so I'm
gonna say I loved Google i/o but the ml
talk was just okay we'll see what it
says this is a review I might find on a
session and let's say that I didn't want
to go through all the sessions but I
wanted to extract key entities and see
what the sentiment was so we can see
here it's extracted two entities Google
i/o and ml talk and we get a score for
each entity the score is a value from
negative one to one that'll tell us
overall how positive or negative is a
sentiment in us and
so Google i/o got 0.8 almost fully
positive we even get a link to the
Wikipedia page for Google i/o and then
ml talk got a neutral score right in the
middle of zero because it was just okay
we also get the aggregate sentiment for
this sentence and we can also look at
the syntax in details see which words
depend on other words get the parts of
speech for all the words in our text and
then if our text was longer than 20
words we could make use of this content
categorization feature which you can
also try right in the browser and you
can see a list of all the categories
that are available for that so that is
the natural language API if we could go
back to the slides so I'm gonna talk
briefly about some companies that are
using these api's in production giffy is
a website that lets you search for gifts
and share them across the web they use
the vision api's optical character
recognition feature to add search by
text functionality to all their gifts so
as you know lots of gifts have text in
them before they use the vision API you
you couldn't search by text and now
they've dramatically increased the
accuracy of their search results Hurst
is a large publishing company and
they're using the natural language api's
content categorization method across
over 30 of their media properties to
categorize their news articles descript
is a new app that lets you transcribe
meetings and interviews and they're
using the speech API for that
transcription so all of these three
companies are using just one API we also
seen a lot of examples of companies
combining different machine learning
api's so seen it is a crowdsource video
platform they've got thousands of videos
uploaded daily so they have no time to
manually tag those videos so using a
combination of video intelligence vision
speech and natural language to
automatically tag all that video content
that they're seeing on the platform
Maslow is a new mobile app it's an audio
journaling app so you can enter your
journal entries through audio and
they're using the speech API to
transcribe that audio and then they're
using the natural language API to
extract key entities give you some
insights
your journal entries and they're doing
all that processing with cloud functions
and storing the data in fire store so
that is the natural language API so all
of the products I've talked about so far
haven't had abstracted that model for
you and a lot of times when I present on
the API as people ask me those API sound
great but what if I want to train them
on my own custom data so we have this
new product that I mentioned called Auto
ml vision it's currently an alpha so you
need to be whitelisted to use it
this lets you train an image
classification model on your own image
data and this is best seen with a demo
so I'm going to introduce it first so
for this demo let's say that I am a
meteorologist
maybe I work at a weather company and I
want to predict weather trends and
flight plans from images of clouds so
the obvious next question is can we use
the cloud to analyze clouds and as I've
learned there's many many different
types of clouds and they all indicate
different weather patterns so when I
first started thinking about this demo I
thought maybe I should try the vision
API first and see what I get back so as
humans if you look at these two images
it's pretty obvious to us that these are
completely different types of clouds the
vision API we wouldn't expect it to know
specifically what type of cloud these
images are it was trained across a wide
variety of images to recognize all sorts
of different products categories but
nothing as specific as this cloud types
for these images so you can see even for
these images of obviously different
clouds we get back pretty similar labels
the sky cloud blue etc so this is where
auto ml vision comes in really handy
Auto ml vision provides a UI to help us
with every step of training our machine
learning model from importing the data
labeling it training it and then
generating predictions using a REST API
so the best way to see it is by again
jumping to a demo so here we have the UI
for auto ml vision again it takes us
through every step of building our model
first up here is importing our data to
do that we put our data in Google Cloud
Storage we put our images in Google
Cloud storage and then we just create a
CSV where the first column and the CSV
is going to be the URL of our image and
in the next column will be the label or
labels associated with that image one
image can have multiple labels so then
we upload our images here I've already
done that for this example then we move
over to the labeling tab and in this
model I've got five different types of
clouds that I'm classifying you can see
them here and we can see how many images
I have for each one Auto ml vision only
requires 10 images per label to start
training they recommend at least a
hundred for high quality predictions so
the next step is to review my image
labels so I can see all my cloud
pictures here I can see what label they
are if this one was incorrect I could go
in here and switch it out well let's say
that I didn't have time to label my
dataset or I have a massive image
dataset I don't have time to label it I
can make use of this human labeling
service which gives you access to a set
of in-house human labelers that will
label your images for you and then in
just a couple of days you'll get back a
labeled image data set so the next part
once you've got your labeled images is
to train your model and you can choose
between a base or advanced model I'll
talk about that more in a moment and to
Train it all you do is press this train
train button it's as simple as that
once your models trained you'll get an
email and the next thing you want to do
is you want to see how this model
performed using some common machine
learning metrics so I'm not going to go
into all of them here but I do want to
highlight the confusion matrix so if it
looks confusing it's called a confusion
matrix but let's take a look at what it
means so for a good confusion matrix
what we ideally want to see is a strong
diagonal from the top left so what this
is telling us is when we uploaded our
images Auto ml it automatically split
our images for us into training and
testing so it took most of our images
use those to train the model and then it
reserved a subset of our images
see how the model performed on images
that I had never seen before so what
this is telling us is that for all of
our altocumulus cloud images in our test
set our model is able to identify 76% of
them correctly which is pretty good now
on the train tab
you saw the base and advanced models and
I've actually trained both so we're
looking at the advanced model here I can
use the UI to see how different versions
of my model performed and compare it so
we would expect that the advanced model
would perform better across the board so
let's take a look so it looks like it
did indeed perform a lot better for most
all of the categories here and see a 23%
increase for this one 11% for this one
but hey wait if we look at our
altostratus images looks like our
advanced model actually did worse on
that what this is actually pointing out
is that there may be some problems with
our training images here so the advanced
model has done a better job of
identifying where there is potentially
problems with our training dataset
because remember our model is only as
good as a training data that we give it
so if you look here we see that 14% of
our altostratus clouds are being
mislabeled as cumulus clouds and if I
click on this I can look and see where
my models getting confused and it turns
out that these are images that I could
have potentially labeled incorrectly I'm
not an expert on actual clouds some of
these images have multiple types of
clouds in them so they actually are
pretty confusing images so what the
confusion matrix can help me do is
identify where I need to go back and
improve my training data so that's the
evaluate tab the next part the most fun
part in my opinion is generating
predictions on new data so I'm going to
take this image of a cirrus cloud and
we're gonna see what our model predicts
again it has never seen this image
before it wasn't used during training
and we'll see how it performs there we
go so we can see that our model is 99
percent confident this is a cirrus cloud
which is pretty cool considering it's
never seen this image before so the UI
is one way that you can generate
predictions once your models been
trained it's a good way to try it out
right after training complete
but chances are you probably want to
build an app that's going to query your
train model and there's a couple
different ways to do this I want to
highlight the vision API here so if you
remember the vision API requests from a
couple slides back you'll notice that
this doesn't look much different all I
need to add is this custom label
detection perimeter and then once my
model trains I get an ID for that train
model that only I have access to or
anybody that I've shared my project with
so if I have an app let's say it's just
detecting whether or not there's a cloud
in an image but then let's say I want to
upgrade my app I want to build a custom
model I don't have to change much at all
about my app architecture to now point
it to my custom model I just need to
modify the request JSON a little bit so
that is Auto ml vision if we could go
back to the slides a little bit about
some companies that are using auto ml
vision and have been part of the Alpha
Disney is the first example they train a
model on different Disney characters
product categories and colors and
they're integrating that into their
search engine to give users more
accurate results Urban Outfitters is a
clothing company they've got a similar
use case they train a model to recognize
different types of clothing patterns and
neckline styles and they're using that
to create a comprehensive set of product
attributes and they're using it to
improve product recommendations and give
users better search results the last
example is Zoological Society of London
they've got cameras deployed all over
the wild and they built a model to
automatically tag all the wildlife that
they're seeing across those cameras so
that they don't need somebody to
manually review it so the two products
I've talked about so far the API is an
auto ml have entirely abstracted the
model from us we don't know anything
about how that model works under the
hood but let's say you've got a more
custom prediction task that's specific
to your data set or use case so one
example is let's say you have just
launched a new product at your company
you're seeing it posted a lot on social
media and you want to identify where in
an image
that product is located you're gonna
need to train a model on your own data
to do that or let's say you've got a lot
of logs coming in and you want to
analyze those logs to find anomalies in
your application these would all require
a custom model train on your own data
we've got two tools to help you do this
tensorflow for building your models and
machine learning engine for training and
serving those models at scale so from
the beginning the Google brain team
wanted everyone in the industry to be
able to benefit from all the machine
learning products they were working on
so they made tensorflow an open-source
project on github and the uptake has
been phenomenal it is the most popular
and machine learning project on github
it has I believe over 90,000 github
stars actually need to update this slide
it just crossed over 13 million
downloads and because it's open source
you can train and serve your tensorflow
models anywhere so once you have built
your tensorflow model you need to think
about training it and then generating
predictions at scale also known as
serving so if your app becomes a major
hit you're getting thousands of
prediction requests per minute you're
gonna need to find a way to serve that
model at scale and again because
tensorflow is open source you can train
and serve your tensorflow models
anywhere but this talk is about Google
cloud platform so I'm going to talk
about our managed service for tensorflow
so on cloud machine learning engine you
can run distributed training with GPUs
and GPUs TV use our custom hardware
designed specifically to accelerate
machine learning workloads and then you
can also deploy your train model to
machine learning engine and then use the
ML engine API to access scaleable online
and batch prediction for your model one
of the great things about ml engine is
that there's no lock-in so let's say
that I want to make use of ml engine for
training my model but then I want to
download my model and serve it somewhere
else
that's really easy to do and I can do
the reverse as well so I'm going to talk
about two different types of custom
models using tensorflow
running on cloud machine learning engine
the first type of custom all don't talk
about is transfer learning which law
says update an existing train model
using our own data and then I'm going to
talk about training a model from scratch
using only your data so transfer
learning is great if you need a custom
model but you don't have quite enough
training data so what this lets us do is
it lets us utilize an existing pre train
model that's been trained on hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of images or
text to do something similar to what
we're trying to do and then we take the
weights of that train model and update
the last couple layers with our own data
so that the outcome is output that's
generating predictions on our own
training data so I wanted to build an
antenna example showing how to train a
model and then go all the way to serving
it and building an app that generates
predictions against it I know a little
bit of Swift so I decided to build an
iOS app that could detect breeds of pets
this is a gif of what the app looks like
so you upload a picture of your pet it's
able to detect where the pet is an image
and what type of breed it is to build
that model I use the tensorflow object
detection API which is a library that's
built on top of tensorflow it's open
source to let you do a specifically
object detection which is identifying a
bounding box of where something is in an
image I train the model on machine
learning engine I also served it on
machine learning engine and then I used
a couple of firebase api's to build a
front-end for my app so this is a full
architecture diagram and the iOS client
is actually a pretty thin client what
it's doing is it's uploading images to
cloud storage for firebase and then I've
got a cloud function that's listening on
that bucket so that function is gonna be
triggered anytime an image is uploaded
it then downloads the image base64
encode zit sends it to machine learning
engine for prediction and then the
prediction that I get back is going to
be a confidence value a label and then
bounding box data for where exactly that
pet is in my image so then I write that
new image with a box around it to cloud
storage and then I store the metadata in
fire store so here's an example showing
how the front-end works so this is a
screenshot a firestore and we can see
that whenever my image data is uploaded
to fire store I write the new image with
the box around it to a cloud storage
bucket so that was an example of
transfer learning but let's say that we
have a custom task and we've got enough
data to build and train a model entirely
from scratch for this I'm going to show
you a demo I built of a model that
predicts the price of wine so I wanted
to see given a wines description and
variety can we predict the price so this
is what an example input and prediction
for our model would be so one reason
this is well-suited for machine learning
is I can't write rules to determine what
the price of this wine should be so I
can't say that any wine with vanilla in
the description and Pinot Noir is gonna
be a mid price wine whereas a fruity
Chardonnay is always gonna be a cheap
wine I can't write rules to do that so I
wanted to see if I could build a machine
learning model to extract insights from
this data as I mentioned because I'm
training this model from scratch there's
no existing model out there that does
exactly this tasks that I want to
perform I'm gonna need a lot of data
I use a Kaggle to get the data Kaggle is
a data science platform it's part of
Google if you're new to machine learning
and looking for interesting datasets to
play around with I definitely recommend
checking out Kaggle so Kaggle has this
wine reviews dataset has data I found
this data set on 150,000 different kinds
of wine for each wine it has a lot of
data on the description the points
rating the price etc so in this I'm just
using the description the variety and
the price for this model so the next
step is to choose that API I'm going to
use to build my model which 10 circle
API and then the type of model I want to
use so I chose to use the TF Kaos API
here so Carris is an open-source machine
learning framework created by francois
shellay who works at Google and the
tensorflow API includes a full
implementation of chaos so chaos is a
higher-level tensorflow API that makes
this easy for us to define the layers of
our model you can also use a lower level
ten ten circle API if you'd like more
control over the different operations in
your
monograph so I chose to use the TF
Kerris API and then I chose to build a
wide and deep model to sell this task
now why didn't deep is basically just a
fancy way of saying I'm gonna represent
the inputs to my model in two different
ways I'm gonna use a linear model the
why that's the wide part that's good at
memorizing relationships between
different inputs and then I'm gonna use
a deep neural net which is really good
at generalizing based on data that it
hasn't seen before put it another way
the input to our wide model is going to
be sparse wide vectors and the input to
our deep model is going to be dense
embedding vectors let's take a look at
what the code for our model will look
like so the first step this is all using
the chaos functional API is to define
the wide model and to represent my text
in my wide model I'm gonna what use
what's called a bag of words
representation so what this does is it
takes all the words that occur across
all my wine descriptions and I'm gonna
choose the top I chose to use the top
12,000 this is kind of a hyper parameter
that you can tune so each input to my
model is going to be a 12,000 element
vector with ones and zeros indicating
whether or not the word from my
vocabulary is present in that specific
description so it doesn't take into
account the order of words or the
relationship between words this wide
model just takes into account whether or
not this word from my vocabulary is
present in that specific description so
the input for this type of input is
gonna look like this it's gonna be a
12,000 element bag of words vector the
way I'm representing my variety my wide
model was pretty simple I've got 40
different wine varieties in my data set
so this is just gonna be a 40 element
one hot vector with each index and the
vector corresponding to a different
variety of wine then I'm going to
concatenate these input layers and the
output to my model is just a float
indicating what the price of that wine
is so if I just wanted to use the wide
model I could take the wide model that I
have here rent training and evaluation
on it using Kerris but I found that I
had better better accuracy when I
combined wide and deep so the next step
is to build my deep model and for my
deep model what I'm using is called an
embedding layer what word embeddings let
us
do is they define the relationships
between words in vector space so words
that are similar to each other are gonna
be closer together in vector space
there's lots of reading out there on
word embeddings so I'm not going to
focus on the details here the way it
works is I can choose the dimensionality
of that space again that's another hyper
parameter of this model so that's
something I should tune and see what
works best for my dataset so in this
case you can see I use an 8 dimensional
embedding space and I obviously I can't
feed the text directly into my model I
need to put it into a format that the
model can understand so what I did was I
encoded each word as an integer so this
is what the input to my deep model is
going to look like and obviously the
inputs needs to be the same length but
not all of my descriptions are the same
length
so I'm using 170 as a link none of my
descriptions are longer than 170 words
so if they're shorter I'll just pad that
vector with zeros at the end as I did
here the output is gonna be the same
we're still predicting the price and
then using the Carrows functional API
it's relatively straightforward to then
combine the outputs from both of these
models and then define my combined model
and so now it's time to run training and
evaluation on that model I chose to do
that using a machine learning engine so
the first step here is to package my
code and put it in Google Cloud Storage
this is pretty simple so I put my model
code in a trainer directory I put my
wine data in a data directory and then I
have this set up top pi file which is
defining the dependencies that my model
is going to use and then to run that
training job I can use g-cloud which is
our google cloud CLI for interacting
with a number of different Google Cloud
products so I run this g-cloud command
to kick off my training job and then I
save my model file which is a binary
file to Google Cloud storage and let's
see a demo of generating some
predictions on that model so for this
demo I'm gonna use this tool called
collab Google collab I'll have a link to
it at the end and this is a cloud hosted
Jupiter notebook that comes with a free
GPU and so here I've already trained my
model and what I'm what I've done is I
saved that model if I
and Google Cloud storage here and now
I'm gonna generate some predictions to
see how it performs on some raw data we
make this a little bit bigger so here
we're just importing some libraries that
we're gonna use I'm loading my model
next step is to load the tokenizer for
my model so this is just an index
associating all the words in my
vocabulary with a number and then I'm
loading my variety encoder too I'm gonna
ignore that warning and here I'm going
to load in some raw data so what I have
here is data on five different wines
I've got the description the variety and
then the Associated price for each of
these wines and I wanted to show you
what the input looks like for each of
these so we need now we now need to
encode each of these into the wide and
deep format that our model is expecting
so to do that we have this vocabulary
lookup I'm just printing a subset of it
here so this is gonna be twelve thousand
elements long for the top twelve
thousand words in our vocabulary and
caris has some utilities to help us
extract those top words and then my
variety encoder is just a 40 element
array that looks like this with each
index corresponding to a different
variety so let's see what the input to
our wide model looks like so the first
thing is our text and this is a bag of
words vector so it's a 12,000 element
vector with zeros and ones indicating
the presence or absence different words
in our vocabulary and then the variety
matrix so I'm just printing it out for
the first one so I believe that first
wine was a Pinot Noir which corresponds
with this index here and if we look up
here we can confirm that yes that was a
Pinot Noir so that's the input to our
wide model and then our deep model we're
just encoding all the words from that
first description as integers and
padding it was zeros since this wasn't a
very long description and then all I
need to do to generate predictions on my
Karros model is called dot predict and
what I'm doing here is I'm now going to
loop through those predictions and see
how the model performed compared to the
actual price so we can see that it did a
pretty good job on the first 146
compared to 48 this one was about $30
off but it was still able to understand
that this was a relatively higher priced
wine
and it did pretty well on the recipes as
well so I'll have a link to this at the
end collab requires zero setup so you
can all go to this URL enter your own
wine descriptions and see how the model
performs if we could go back to the
slides I'm going to talk briefly about a
few companies they're using a tensor
flow and machine learning engine in
production to build custom models the
first example is rolls-royce they're
using a custom tensor flow model in
their marine division to identify and
track the objects that a vessel can
encounter at C o kado is the UK's
largest grocery delivery service so as
you can imagine they get tons and tons
of customer support emails every day and
they've built a custom model it's able
to take those emails and predict whether
it requires an urgent response or maybe
the email doesn't require a response at
all and they've been able to save a lot
of customer support time using that
model and then finally Airbus has built
a custom image classification model to
identify things in satellite imagery so
I know I covered a ton of different
products I wanted to give you a summary
of what resources all of these products
require so these are just four resources
that I thought of that you need to solve
a machine learning problem there's
probably more that I don't have on here
first is training data how much training
data do you need to provide to train
your model how much model code do you
need how much training are serving
infrastructure do you need to provision
and then overall how long is this task
gonna take you so if you look at our
machine learning api's great thing about
these you don't need any training data
you can just start generating prediction
on one image you don't need to write any
of the model code you don't need to
provision any training or serving
infrastructure and you can probably get
started with these in less than a day
very little time we move to auto ml the
cool thing about Auto ml is that you
will provide some of your own training
data because you're going to be creating
a more customized model and it'll take a
little more time because you will need
to spend some time processing those
images uploading uploading them to the
cloud and maybe labeling them
you still don't need any model code or
any training or serving infrastructure
and then finally if we think about a
custom model built with tensorflow
running on cloud ml engine you will need
a lot of training data you will have to
write a lot of the model code yourself
and you'll need to think about whether
you want to run your training and
serving jobs on-premise or if you want
to use a managed service like cloud ml
engine to do that for you and obviously
this this process will take a little bit
more time finally so if you remember
only three things from this presentation
so I know I covered a lot first thing
can use a pre trained API to accomplish
common machine learning tasks like image
analysis natural language processing or
translation second thing if you want to
build an image classification API train
on your own data use auto ml vision I'm
really interested to hear if you have a
specific use case for auto ml vision
come find me after I'll be in the cloud
sandbox area last thing for custom
machine learning tests you can build a
tensor flow model with your own data and
train and serve it on machine learning
engine so here is a lot of great
resources covering everything I talked
about today I'll let all of you take a
picture of that slide the video will
also be up after so you can grab it from
there as well and that's all I've got
thank you
[Music]